con la vista puesta en los altísimos
precios de la energía los líderes
europeos se reúnen en Praga para abordar
qué más se puede hacer para aliviar los
precios de la electricidad ahora mismo
después de semanas de discusiones no se
ha podido llegar a ningún punto en común
Así que hoy se espera que se empiece a
discutir que más se puede hacer en
cualquier caso hasta 15 países han
enviado una carta a la comisión europea
pidiendo un límite al precio de todo el
gas no solo el proveniente de Rusia
porque recordemos es el gas el que
dictamina los precios de la electricidad
presionada al respecto la presión de la
comisión europea Úrsula fonterleyen
Finalmente accedido y ha propuesto que
se limite el precio del gas aún faltan
los detalles y de hecho hay varias
propuestas una de las que se está
estudiando Es que este límite del gas
sea flexible según la situación del
mercado Aunque hay otras propuestas
encima de la mesa y se espera que los
líderes empiecen a centrar un poco la
discusión para poder llegar a una
aprobación formal a finales de este mes
una reunión en Bruselas también se
estudia otras cuestiones como una
posible emisión de deuda conjunta para
así poder pagar las facturas de los
ciudadanos y también de las empresas y
así evitar casos como el de Alemania que
anunciado un plan de 200.000 millones de
euros para ayudar a sus ciudadanos y a
sus empresas que no ha sentado nada bien
entre sus socios europeos que consideran
que no es justo porque muchos no pueden
aplicar los mismos planes en sus países